hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Tom who was an
aspiring entrepreneur and wants to know
if he should include video on his
website or not so Tom I love the use of
video I think you can use it for two
main reasons the first is to quickly
explain what your product or service
does so a lot of people have short
attention spans and a visual learner so
video is a great way to quickly
communicate a message to them if I go to
a website and I get pitched all day long
I have tons of emails come in and people
saying check out my website please and
what do you think of my product or
service if I can quickly hit their
website and see a video that explains
what they do then I can quickly get a
sense of if I want to you know do
something with this company or not if
it's going to take half an hour to dig
in and really figure out what this
business is all about then you're going
to lose most people so I really like the
idea of having a quick video to quickly
explain what your product or service
does to tell prospects who are landing
on your website a great example of this
is Dropbox so if you go to dropbox com
you'll see their homepage is just a
video and it quickly explains the need
and why you can use Dropbox and how you
can use Dropbox and allows you to make a
quick decision if the service is right
for you or not I'm a panelist on a show
called the pitch where entrepreneurs
come on pitch their ideas looking for
capital and in advance we kind of get
the websites of everybody's coming on
the pitch and I'll always go quickly
check it out and see if they have a
video because if I can quickly see a two
minute video that explains what they do
I get a sense of what the company is all
about or if they don't have a video and
I have to kind of dig through pages of
product information that's that's more
cumbersome and I'm less likely to do it
so if you can have that quick video it
goes a long way to being able to make an
impact with people who are visiting your
site the second type of video that can
also be really helpful is having
testimonials so if you have people from
your client base or people who've worked
with you in the past say how great you
are that goes a long way to establishing
credibility with new people who are
coming to visit your website so if you
create a video with you saying how great
you are of course you're gonna say how
great you are cuz
your own products of service so people
will take that with a grain of salt and
may not believe it too much but if you
have your clients coming on and people
work with you in the past and they're
saying how great you are then people who
are visiting your site looking at that
there's a little bit more credibility
and they're more likely you're going to
want to work with you I said I'd give
you to tip so I'm gonna give you one
more because it just came to mind is
we're recording this another thing that
could be really helpful for you is if
you talk a little bit about yourself I
find that people like buying from people
instead of companies and this was a
mistake I made earlier on with my
business where the company was Evan
chemical calm but all i did was profile
famous entrepreneurs and i was never
involved and people are asking who's
Evan chemical where is he we should see
more of him and so I started you know
putting myself on there more and
creating these videos and I think for
any company is an opportunity for the
founder to create a relationship with
their customers our client base and
website visitors by creating a quick
intro video talk a little bit but you
talk about your story talked about why
you started your business and people are
more interested in that than just your
kind of company overview standard bio so
it's a three-way I think you can really
use video to get people to know you like
you'll want to work with you so
hopefully that was helpful I love to
hear you guys have to think if you want
to leave a comment under the video and
if you like the video please give it a
thumbs up I always appreciate those and
stay tuned for next episode
you